The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: OK, I want to take
10 more seconds now the
clicker slide.
This is giving us one more try
on the vsper geometries,
because it didn't go so
well on Wednesday.
All right, excellent.
So that is a very good job.
Let's quickly go over why.
We have p h 3.
We told you that phosphorous has
5 valence electrons plus 3
from each of the hydrogens,
so we have a total
of 8 valence electrons.
How many do we need to get
full valence shells
everywhere?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: 14.
So, we need 14 minus 8.
That leaves us with 6
bonding electrons.
And if we put that in our bond
here, we have 1, 2, 3 bonds,
plus we have one lone
pair left over.
So this is our Lewis
structure here.
If these bonds were all
completely of equal distance
apart, whether is was a lone
pair or bonding electrons, the
angles would be 109 .
5 degrees.
But because there's this lone
pair here, it's pushing down
on the other bonds, so we
end up with an angle of
less than 109 .
5 degrees.
All right, so let's switch
over to notes for today.
So we're going to finish
talking about molecular
orbital theory, and then we'll
switch over to discussing
bonding in larger molecules,
even larger than diatomic, so
we'll move on to talking about
valence bond theory and
hybridization.
So, clearly you don't have your
notes in front of you
yet, so you can just listen,
take it all in.
What I'll do is I'll post the
notes filled in to the point
where you actually get your
class notes today.
So, this will be a little bit
more like a seminar to start
with, and a little bit less
like a lecture in class.
But let's go ahead and start
our discussion in terms of
molecular orbital theory.
So where we had left off with
was we'd fully discussed up to
the point of considering
homonuclear diatomic
molecules, so molecules that
both have the same nucleus.
And where we had left off was
we were going to start one
example of thinking about now
where we have a heteronuclear
diatomic molecules, so two
different atoms in terms of
forming the molecule.
But first, I just want to remind
you when we're talking
about molecular orbital theory,
this is treating
electrons as waves, so what
we're actually able to do is
either constructively or
destructively combine atomic
orbitals to form molecular
orbitals.
So you should remember that
any time we combine 2 s
orbitals, what we're going to
find is if we constructively
interfere those two orbitals,
we're going to
form a bonding orbital.
And that's going to be lower
in energy than the two
individual atomic orbitals.
And we call that, for this case,
our sigma 2 s orbital.
In contrast, if we have
destructive interference, what
we're going to form is a sigma
2 s star, and what does the
star designate?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Anti-bonding, yup.
So it's an Anti-bonding
orbital.
It's going to be higher in
energy than the individual
atomic orbitals.
All right, great.
So, I think we have these
molecular orbital energies
down, so let's move on
to talking about
more complex molecules.
And to do this we're going to
introduce valence bond theory,
and the idea of hybridization
of orbitals.
So the idea behind valence bond
theory is very easy to
understand.
Essentially what you have is
bonds resulting from the
pairing of unpaired electrons.
So the simplest case we can
think of is with h 2 where we
have two unpaired electrons,
each in a 1 s orbital of a
separate h atom.
And if we picture those two
coming together, we form the h
2 molecule.
And again, we have the pairing
of the unpaired electrons, and
we have two orbitals
coming together.
So in molecular orbital theory,
what we did was we
named orbitals based
on their symmetry.
In valence bond theory, the
focus is on discussing the
bonds, but it should look very
familiar to you, because
there's two types of bonds that
we want to discuss here.
We want to discuss sigma
bonds and pi bonds.
So this is very similar to what
we saw in terms of sigma
orbitals and pi orbitals.
So in this first case
here, what we're
seeing is a sigma bond.
And a sigma bond forms any time
you have two orbitals
coming together and interacting
on that
internuclear axis.
So we talk about a sigma bond
as being cylindrically
symmetric about the bond axis,
and it's important to point
out that it has no nodal plane
across this bond axis.
This is in direct contrast
to when we're
thinking about pi bonds.
So pi bonds have electron
density both above and below
the bond axis, but they actually
have a nodal plane at
this z, this bond axis here.
And remember for this class,
we always define z as the
internuclear or the bond axis.
So it might look like here, if
you don't understand about p
orbitals, which I know all you
do, but if someone else was
just looking and seeing, it kind
of looks like there's two
bonds here.
There's not two bonds, that's
one pi bond, and the reason is
because it's 2 p orbitals coming
together, and remember
p orbitals have electron density
above and below the
axis, so when they come
together, it kind of looks
like one bonds, but essentially
what we have here
is one pi bond.
So let's think about how we can
classify single and double
and triple bonds, which is
what we're really used to
dealing with in terms
of these sigma bonds
and these pi bonds.
So, if we take a look at what
a single bond is, and let me
grab some molecules here.
If we're talking about a single
bond, we're talking
about 2 orbitals overlapping
in the internuclear axis.
So if we have a single bond
here, would you consider that
a sigma bond or a pi bond?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, it's
a sigma bond.
Essentially what we're
seeing is overlapping
in this z axis here.
In contrast, if we talk about a
double bond, what we're now
talking about is having
both a sigma bond
and also one pi bond.
And I apologize, I intended to
set this up right before
class, but that didn't
happen today.
All right, so what we see here
is we have our sigma bond
that's along the internuclear
axis here, but we also have a
pi bond, because each of these
atoms now has electrons in
it's in a p orbital, so we're
going to overlap of electron
density above and
below the bond.
So that's exactly what our
definition of a pi bond is, so
we have one sigma bond,
and one pi bond.
So now let's think about
a triple bond.
A triple bond, again is going to
have one sigma bond on the
internuclear axis.
How many pi bonds would
you expect?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Two, great.
So, we're going to
see two pi bonds.
The first one will be above
and below the bond axis is
where we'll see the electron
density, and the second will
be perpendicular to that, so it
will be a density in front
of and behind the bond axis.
So we can kind of flip it this
way -- this will be one pi
bond, this will be another
interacting
between these p orbitals.
All right, so that's really all
there is to thinking about
valence bond theory in
terms of the most
simple explanation here.
But what we're going is we're
going to start trying to apply
it to a molecule, and I actually
picked a molecule
that it's not going to work for,
even though it would work
even just at this level for
many, many molecules.
And I picked looking at methane
so we could see if
there are other factors that
we're not considering, that we
need to maybe tweak our model
a little bit, and I think
we'll find that we do if we take
a look at a polyatomic
molecule, methane, so c h 4.
So let's think about methane
using valence bond theory.
So, using our simple valence
bond theory, what we would
expect is that we want to pair
up any unpaired electrons in
methane with unpaired electrons
from hydrogen and
form bonds.
But what we see we have is that
we only have two unpaired
electrons here.
Because we have paired set in
a 2 s orbital, so all we're
left essentially is two
electrons that are available
for bonding.
So this should immediately look
like a problem because we
know, in fact, that methane is
tetravalent, and this is
telling us it's only divalent.
Essentially it would only allow
for us to bond to two
hydrogen atoms. So if it did
this, it now looks like, from
looking at the paired electrons
that we have a
stable structure here, and our
structure is not c h 4, it's a
stable structure of c h 2, and
it will actually predict,
also, what this h c h
bond angle it is.
So according to this model
what is that bond angle?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: One more time.
OK, I hear a mix.
So, according to this model,
what we're seeing is a bond
angle of 90 degrees.
What do you know the bond
angle should be?
It's 109 .
5 is what we would expect
for methane because it's
tetravalent, but here we're just
seeing something that's
divalent, and they're both
in p orbitals that are
perpendicular to each other.
So what we're predicting is a
bond angle of 90 degrees.
This is totally wrong, this is
the wrong picture altogether.
If you had your notes, you could
do some fun scribbling
right now, so you can
do that at home.
We're going to need to tweak our
explanation here, and take
into account another factor,
and that factor is the fact
that we know that we must have
four unpaired electrons in
carbon if we're going
to form four bonds.
So the way that we can explain
this is through something
called electron promotion and
hybridization of atomic orbitals.
So let's take a look at
what we mean by this.
So if we take our carbon atom
here, which has two electrons
in the 2 s orbital, and we
promote one of these electrons
into a 2 p orbital, what we see
now is that yes, we do, we
have four unpaired electrons.
So, looking at this,
this might not
look so good for you.
What we're proposing here is
that you take a nice low
energy s electron and
move it into a
higher energy p orbital.
And the truth is that yes, this
costs energy, we're going
up to a higher energy state.
But it doesn't actually cost
as much energy as you might
think, because in this s orbital
here we have a paired
electron situation where we're
moving up to a p orbital where
the electron is no longer
paired, so it won't feel quite
as much electron repulsion, but
nonetheless, this is going
to cost us energy.
So we'll have to think about
where that energy is going to
come from and we'll see
that in just a minute.
But let's assume that this is,
in fact, going to happen.
So now what we have is four
unpaired electrons.
That's great, but it's still not
quite the picture we need,
because actually, all the
electrons are not in equal
orbitals -- one's in an s
orbital, and 3 are in p.
But what we need to remember is
the fact that we're talking
about electrons which
are waves.
When we're talking about
orbitals, we're talking about
wave functions.
So we can actually
constructively and
destructively combine these
waves, these atomic orbitals
to make a hybrid.
So if we go ahead and hybridize
our p orbitals and
our s orbitals, we'll switch
from having these original
orbitals to having something
called hybrid orbitals.
And hybrid orbitals are all
going to be completely equal,
and you'll notice that they're
higher in energy than the s
orbital, and lower in energy
than the p orbital.
That should make sense because
they come from combining s
orbitals and p orbitals.
And specifically, when we give
them a name it's very clear
exactly which orbitals they
come from combining, we're
calling these s p 3 orbitals
-- that's because they come
from combining 1 s orbital
and 3 p orbitals.
You should never get the names
of hybrid orbitals wrong
because it's very
straightforward.
If it has 1 s and 3 p's,
we call it s p 3.
Naming doesn't always make sense
in chemistry, so I like
to point out this is a place
where naming does
make a lot of sense.
All right, so let's consider our
methane situation now that
we have our hybrid orbitals.
So I want to mention also, these
are exactly equivalent,
they're equivalent in energy,
they're equivalent in shape.
The only thing that is different
about these orbitals
is their orientation in space.
So actually, first let's
take a look at how
we got these orbitals.
We got them from combining
again, 1 s
orbital and the 3 p orbitals.
If we hybridize these, what we
end up seeing are these four
hybrid orbitals.
You'll notice the shape is the
same, all that's different is
their orientation.
So essentially, each of these
orbitals come from linear
combinations of all of the
original orbitals, and it's
hard to picture exactly how that
happens, but one that you
can at least start to get an
idea is if you think about
combining the 2 s and the 2 p
z here, which is not quite
accurate because of course,
we're combining all of them.
But it would just give
you a little bit
of an idea of shape.
You can see if we combine the s
with the top lobe of the p,
they're going to constructively
interfere
because they have
the same sign.
So you see in the hybrid orbital
we actually have a
larger lobe on top where they
constructively interfered.
If you compare the s orbital
with the bottom lobe, these
have a different sign
so they're going to
destructively interfere.
So what you see is actually a
diminished lobe on the back
part of this s p 3 orbital.
So s p 3 orbitals always have
one huge lobe and one really
little lobe.
A lot of times when people draw
them, they even only draw
the big lobe just to keep their
paper looking nicer, but
there is that little tiny
lobe on the other side.
All right, so in terms of s
p 3 hybrid orbitals, let's
combine all four together on
one axis, because this is
what's going to happen in
an s p 3 carbon atom.
So in this case, what
would you say that
the angle is here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Right, great.
So, we've achieved the angle
that we observed, which is
good, which is a 109 .
5.
So we can think about now doing
bonding, and now we have
four equal orbitals with
one electronic each.
So we can bring in four hydrogen
atoms, which will
each contribute another
unpaired electron.
So now what we have
is four bonds.
And we can think about where
we did get that energy for
electron promotion that I
mentioned before where we
moved the electron from
the 2 s to the 2 p.
We get that from bonding.
We're going to release a lot
of energy for bonding, it's
going to more than make up for
the fact that we actually had
to spend some energy to
promote that electron.
So, we can think about now how
do we describe this bond in
valence bond theory.
So the way that you describe
a bond is you describe the
orbitals that the bond comes
from, and also the
symmetry of the bond.
So would you expect this
to be a pi bond or
a sigma bond here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so I'm hearing
some mixed answers.
It turns out that it's
a sigma bond.
The reason that it's a sigma
bond is because the s p 3
hybrid orbital is directly
interacting with the 1 s
orbital of the hydrogen atom,
and that's going to happen on
the internuclear axis, they're
just coming together.
Any time two orbitals come
straight on together in that
internuclear axis, you're going
to have a sigma bond.
So if we go ahead and name this
bond, what we're going to
name it is sigma, because that's
the -- basically the
shape of the bond or
that's how our
bond is coming together.
And then we're going to name the
atomic orbitals that make
it up, and it's being made up
of a carbon 2 s p 3 orbital,
and a hydrogen 1 s orbital.
All right, so let's think of
a case now that's getting a
little bit more complicated.
We were talking about
methane, which has
only one central atom.
We can also talk about atoms
that have two or more central
atoms. So let's talk about
ethane now, which is c h 2.
So let's take our carbon s p 3
hybridized carbon and just
move it around here so we can
make the z inter- bonding axis
between the two carbons
right here.
So if we still have an
angle of a 109 .
5 degrees, and again, we still
have four unpaired electrons
available for bonding, we can
make one of those bonds with
another s p 3 hybridized carbon,
so we're going to make
up one pair here.
If we think about that, that's
a sigma bond, right, they're
coming together along
the nuclear axis.
We also have six spots available
to form hydrogen
bonds, so we can go ahead
and fill in those
electrons as well.
So in terms of thinking about
ethane, we actually have two
bond types that we're going to
be describing just in terms of
the carbon-carbon bond and
then the carbon h bonds.
So let's talk about ethane and
how we would actually write
these bonds.
If we have the molecule ethane,
then what we're going
to have first is our sigma bond
that we described between
the two carbons.
So it's going to be carbon,
and then what's the
hybridization here?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: All right, start
again, what's the
hybridization of the
carbon atom?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: OK, so it's 2 s p
3, and our second carbon is
also 2 s p 3.
All right, so this is our
first type of bond here.
Our second bond is going to be
between the carbon and the
hydrogen atoms. Is that
a sigma or a pi bond?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sigma, good.
So again, our carbon is
going to be 2 s p 3.
And what will our hydrogen be?
1 s -- we don't have to
hybridize it, it already has
only one unpaired electron
in a 1 s orbital.
All right, so that's how
we describe ethane.
We don't have to just stick
with carbon, we can think
about describing other types
of atoms as well using this
hybridization.
For example, we can talk about
nitrogen, and nitrogen has
five valence electrons
shown here.
Would you expect to see electron
promotion in nitrogen
where we pull one of these
2 s electrons into
one of the 2 p orbitals?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: No, good.
So, electron promotion does
not happen in terms of
nitrogen, because it would not
increased our number of
unpaired electrons.
No matter what we do in terms
of promotion, we're always
going to have three unpaired
electrons.
We can still hybridize all these
orbitals, however, so we
can still form four hybrid
orbitals, which are again, 2 s
p 3 hybrid orbitals.
So if we take a look at nitrogen
here, what you'll
notice is we have thre available
for bonding, and we
already have our lone pair
-- one of our orbitals is
already filled up.
So we can add three hydrogen
atoms here, and fill in our
other orbitals right here.
So if we do this and we form
the molecule ammonia, let's
switch to a clicker question,
and have you tell me what the
bond angle is going to
be in ammonia --
the h n h bond angle.
Actually, let me draw it on
the board as you look --
actually, can you put the class
notes on, since you
don't actually have your
notes to refer to.
So there's the class
notes there.
All right, this should be a
pretty quick thing for you to
figure out, so let's just
take 10 seconds on this.
OK, great.
Even thinking quickly, most
of you got it correct.
So what we see is on ammonia
here, we know that it's less
than a 109 .
5, it's actually 107, so
it's less than a 109 .
5, because of that lone
pair pushing down
in the bonding electrons.
And what is the shape,
for one more
clicker question on ammonia?
Let's take 10 seconds again,
this should be pretty quick.
All right, pretty good.
So, 70% of you.
We'd like to get
this up higher.
The shape is actually
trigonal pyramidal.
And you need to just remember
your shapes.
If they're not obvious to you
what they're called, you need
to just study them
and learn them.
So it's trigonal because we have
these three atoms that
are bound to the central atom
here, and if you picture it,
it's actually shaped
like a pyramid.
So it's trigonal pyramidal.
That's what we call when we have
three bonding atoms and
one lone pair.
All right.
So we can switch all the way
back to our notes here.
And the last thing we can think
about is how do we name
this n h bond, and again,
we just name
it based on it symmetry.
It's a sigma bond, and it's
going to be -- no.
OK, it's going to be nitrogen
2 s p 3, because it's a
nitrogen atom, and then
hydrogen 1 s.
So, I don't even have to worry
because you're not writing
this down, so I can just fix it
when I post the notes and
no one will ever know, except
that this is not
OpenCourseWare.
So let's switch to thinking
about oxygen
hybridization here.
So in oxygen we have a similar
situation where, in fact, we
are not going to promote any
of the electrons because we
have two lone pair electrons
no matter what we do.
So when we hybridize our
orbitals, we're going to end
up with again, four hybrid
orbitals, 4 s p 3 orbitals,
and what we'll see is that two
of these are already going to
be filled up with a paired
electrons, so we're only going
to have 2 orbitals with an
unpaired electron available
for bonding.
So let's think about water here
as our simplest example
with oxygen.
So we can have our two hydrogen
atoms come in here,
and what we will find is now
that we have all of our
orbitals filled up -- so
thinking about what this angle
is here, would you expect it
to be less than or greater
than what we saw for
ammonia before?
STUDENT: Less than.
PROFESSOR: Good, good, it's
going to be less than, and
it's going to be less
than because now we
have two lone pairs.
So since we have two lone
pairs, we're going to be
pushing down even further on
the bonding electrons, so
we're going to smoosh those
bonds even closer together.
The bond, it turns
out, is 104 .
5 degrees, that h o h bond.
So in terms of naming our o h
bond, good, it's right here.
So it's going to be a sigma
bond, and we have oxygen 2 s p
3 and hydrogen 1 s.
And the geometry, which I didn't
ask you, is going to be
bent for this molecule.
All right, so that's s p 3
hybridization, but those
aren't the only type of hybrid
orbitals that we can form.
Let's take a look at what
happens if instead of
combining all four orbitals, we
just combine three of those
orbitals, and what we'll
end up with is s p 2
hybridization.
So in s p 2 hybridization,
instead of combining all four,
we're just combining
two of the p
orbitals with the s orbital.
So what we're going to
end up with now is
three hybrid orbitals.
And what happens to this last
p orbital is nothing at all,
we just get it back.
So we end up with 1 p orbital
completely untouched, and
three hybrid s p 2 orbitals.
So again, we can think
of an example here.
So let's take boron, for
example, and this has -- it
starts off with three
valence electrons.
Would you expect to see electron
promotion for boron?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, absolutely.
if we move up one of our
electrons into an empty p
orbital, what were going to
see is now we have three
unpaired electrons that are
ready for bonding.
So, if we hybridize just these
three orbitals, what we're
going to end up with is our
s p 2 hybrid orbitals.
Again, the name is very
straightforward, it comes from
1 s and 2 p orbital, so
it will be s p 2.
And again, you might be thinking
well, why didn't we
actually hybridize this
2 p y orbital.
It doesn't actually have an
electron in it, so we don't
have to worry about whether it's
very high in energy or
not, we don't care that
it's high in energy.
What we do care about is the
energy of our orbitals that
have electrons in them, and if
we combined all four of the
orbitals, then our hybrid
orbitals would have more p
character to them, so they'd
actually be higher in energy.
So if we don't have to hybridize
one of the p
orbitals, we can actually end
up with a lower energy
situation, because now these
s p 2 orbitals are 1/3 s
character, and only 2/3 p
character, instead of 3/4.
So we end up with 3 s p 2 hybrid
orbitals, so we can
think about what would happen
here in terms of bonding, and
if we think about how to get
our bonds as far away as
possible from each other, what
we're going to have is the
trigonal planer situation.
So if you picture, for example,
b h 3, it's going to
look like this.
All of our electrons are in our
bonds, we want to got them
a 120 degrees away from each
other, that's as far away as
we can get them.
Keep in mind we do have this p
orbital here and it's coming
right out at us.
And this p orbital is here,
but it's empty, it doesn't
have any electrons in it, that's
why we don't have to
worry about it in terms of
getting our electrons as far
away from each other
as possible.
So what we'll have here is a
trigonal planar case, and you
can see that we only have three
electrons that are set
for bonding, so we'll add three
hydrogens, and for b h
3, we'll get a stable
structure here.
So, remember, boron was one of
those exceptions to our Lewis
structure rules where it was
perfectly happy not having a
full octet.
So this can tell you why it's so
happy with only having six
electrons around it.
All right, so if we think about
b h bond here, again,
it's the sigma bond, and we're
going to say it's a boron 2 s
p 2 hybrid orbital interacting
with a hydrogen 1 s orbital.
So let's take a look at another
case where we have s p
2 hybridization, we can
actually also have
it happen in carbon.
So if we think about having
it happen in carbon, we're
starting with the situation
where we've already promoted
our electron into a 2 p orbital
here, and what we're
going to do is just combine the
s and two of the p's, so
we'll end up with electrons
in one of each three
s p 2 hybrid orbitals.
But unlike the case with boron
where we had an empty p
orbital, we're actually going
to have an electron in the p
orbital of carbon as well.
So again, if we think about
that shape of that carbon
atom, it's going to be trigonal
planar, it's going to
have bond angles of 120 degrees,
because we have this
set up of having three
hybrid orbitals.
So let's take a look at what
actually happens if we're
talking about a carbon-carbon
double bond, such as in
ethene, c 2 h 4, we're going
to have a double bond.
If we have a double bond, we
know we need to have only one
sigma bond, and we're also going
to have one pi bond.
So it already should make
sense why we have that p
orbital there, in order to form
a pi bond, we're going to
need a p orbital.
So if you picture this as our
s p 2 carbon atom where we
have three hybrid orbitals,
and then one p y orbital
coming right out at us.
So again, we picture the same
thing as we pictured with the
boron there.
If we have, coming along this
z axis, another carbon atom,
we can actually form one
bond between the two
carbon atoms there.
So if we picture how this
happens, what we have here if
these are our 2 s p 2 carbon
atoms -- so here we have s p 2
hybrid carbon, and here we have
s p 2 hybrid carbon atom.
These 2 are going to come
together like this, and the
first bond that we're going to
form is going to be a sigma
bond, right, so we
see that here.
If we're looking head on, we
see they form a sigma bond.
We can also look at them coming
in from the side, and
that's what I tried to depict
here where you can actually
see in pink is the p orbital.
So we can also show them coming
together this way, so
now you're looking at it where
you can see the p orbital, and
maybe just see well one
of the hydrogen atoms.
So we can have four total
hydrogens bonding here, and we
can think about how
to describe these
carbon-carbon bonds.
So in the first case of this
first bond here that I've put
in a square, what type
of a bond is this, is
the sigma or pi?
STUDENT: Sigma.
PROFESSOR: Yup, it's
a sigma bond.
We're having two
orbitals coming
together on the bond axis.
So we'll call this sigma, and
it's between two s p 2 hybrid
carbon atoms. So it's stigma
carbon s p 2, carbon s p 2.
What about this second bond here
where we're going to have
interaction of 2 p orbitals,
is that sigma or pi?
STUDENT: Pi.
PROFESSOR: Pi, great.
So our second bond is going
to be a pi bond.
And again, this is between the
p orbitals, these are not
hybrid orbitals, so when we name
this bond we're going to
name it as a pi bond here,
because it's between two p
orbitals, and it's going to be
between the carbon 2 p y
orbital, and the other
carbon 2 p y orbital.
Remember, we didn't hybridize
the 2 p y orbital, so that's
what we have left over to
form these pi bonds.
All right.
So in addition to having these
two carbon bonds, we actually
also have four carbon hydrogen
bonds in addition to our
carbon-carbon bonds.
So why don't you tell me what
the valence bond description
would be of these carbon
hydrogen bonds?
So let's take 10 seconds
on that.
OK, great.
So most and you got it, so we
can switch to the notes and
let's talk about this here.
So in terms of the carbon
hydrogen bond, it's a sigma
bond, because we define it --
any time we are bonding to an
atom, we have to keep redefining
our bond axis to
whatever two atoms we're
talking about.
So it's along the bond axis and
it's between a carbon s p
2 hybrid, and then the hydrogen
is just a 1 s orbital
that we're combining here.
So those are our three types
of bonds in ethene.
One thing that I want to
mention that is really
important is once you have
double bonds, what happens
between those two atoms in the
molecule is they can no longer
rotate in relation
to each other.
So you can think about
why that is.
When we have just a single bond
in them molecule, you
have all the free rotation you
want, you can just spin it
around, there's nothing
keeping it in place.
But once you have a double
bond here, we have our pi
bond, as well as
our sigma bond.
So there's electron density
above the bond
and below the bond.
So if I try to rotate my 2
atoms, you see that I have to
break that pi bond, because they
need to be lined up so
that the electron density
can overlap.
So in order to rotate a double
bond, you have to actually
break the pi bond, so
essentially what you're doing
is breaking the double bond.
So really, you can not ever
rotate a double bond, it makes
your molecule very rigid.
This is incredibly important
because if you picture having
a double bond in a very large
molecule, you could have all
sorts of other atoms off this
way and all sorts of other
atoms off this way, and you can
picture the shape would be
very different if you have one
confirmation versus another
confirmation.
So it's very important that the
double bond locks it in a
particular conformation.
This completely could change if
you were to flip from one
to the other conformation
which can
happen in chemical reactions.
If you were to make that change
you would find that the
molecule now has completely
different biological and
chemical properties.
So it's very important to be
keeping in mind that any time
you see a double bond, you
have a pi bond there, so
you're not going to see any
rotation around the bond axis.
All right, so let's think of a
more complicated example of
having a double bond, and
maybe a more interesting
example, and this is talking
about benzene.
I think most and you have talked
a little bit about
benzene over this past
week in recitation.
Benzene is a ring that's made up
of six carbon atoms and six
hydrogen atoms. So let's picture
what this looks like
here, and we'll start
with four and we'll
add in our last two.
So essentially, we have two
ethene or ethylene molecules
here to start with where these
blue are our 2 s p 2 hybrid
orbitals, so you can see that
for each carbon atom, one is
already used up binding to
another carbon atom.
If we think about bringing in
those last two carbons, what
you can see is that for every
carbon, two of its hybrid
orbitals are being used to
bond to other carbons.
So that leaves each carbon
with only one
hybrid orbital left.
And if we think about the six
hydrogens, now each of those
are going to bind by combining
one of the carbon hybrid
orbitals to a 1 s orbital
of hydrogen.
So, if we think about what bonds
are in this molecule, we
actually have six of these
sigma carbon s p 2,
carbon s p 2 bonds.
We also have carbon s p
2 hydrogen 1 s bonds.
How many of those do we have?
Yup, we also have six of these,
because we have six
carbon hydrogen bonds.
So that's two of our types of
bonds in benzene, and we have
one type left, and that's
going to actually be the
double bond or the pi bond that
forms between some of
these p orbitals.
So we can have one bond here
between this carbon's p
orbital and this carbon's
p orbital.
So let's have a clicker question
here on how many
total pi bonds do you expect
to see in benzene?
Oh good, so it's left up -- the
notes are left up on this
screen right now.
All right, so let's take
10 seconds on that.
All right, great.
So, most of you saw that what
we would expect to see is a
three bond, some of
you thought six.
So let's take a look at
why three is correct.
So, what we end up having
is three of these pi --
2 p y 2 p y bonds, we
can have one between
these two carbons here.
Can we have one between
these two carbons here
if we have one here?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: No, we can't.
We're already using it up in
this pi bond here, so that
means we're limited to only
two other spots on the
molecule, so we have three.
But, of course, what you saw in
recitation, and hopefully,
what you can now think very
quickly by looking at this, is
that this is not the only
configuration of pi bonds that
we could have in benzene.
There's absolutely no reason
I couldn't have switched it
around and said that instead the
pi orbitals form between
these atoms instead of those
first atoms I showed.
So, let's look at this in a
more simple structure here
where we have the two possible
forms of benzene, and the
reality is is that it's
going to be some
combination of the two.
This is resonance, this is a
case of a resonance structure.
So what we see is that those six
pi electrons are actually
going to be de-localized around
all six of those atoms.
So if you think about any one of
these carbon-carbon bonds,
what type of a bond would
you expect that to be?
What would the bond order
be for this bond?
STUDENT: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Yup, it's going
to be a 1 and 1/2 bond.
It's a 1 and 1/2 because it's
halfway between a double bond
and a single bond.
So, of course, this is resonance
so we can go ahead
and put our resonance notation
in there to indicate that
benzene is a resonance
structure.
All right.
So let's quickly talk about our
last type of hybridization
that we're going to discuss
today, which is s p
hybridization.
So s p hybridization comes now
from when we're combining an s
orbital now with only
one p orbital.
So let's take a look at
this with carbon.
And if we hybridize these
orbitals in carbon, what we
end up with is having two hybrid
orbitals, and then
we're going to be left with two
of our p orbitals that are
each going to have an electron
associated in them.
So again, looking at the
shapes, now we're just
combining two, we've got these
two equal hybrid orbitals plus
these 2 p orbitals here.
So let's take the case of
acetylene where we have two
carbon atoms that are going to
be triple bonded to each
other, each are bonded
to a carbon
and then to one hydrogen.
So this is a little bit trickier
to look at and see
what it means, but essentially
we have two hybrid orbitals,
which are shown in blue here,
and then we have one p orbital
that's left alone that's going
up and down on the page.
And then that second p orbital's
actually coming
right out at you, it's coming
out of the screen at you.
So, if we think about this z
bonding axis between the two
carbon atoms, we can picture
overlap of those s p hybrid
orbitals, and then we can also
picture bonding to hydrogen.
So, in a settling, what is
the bond angle here?
This is the easiest question
all day, what is the bond
angle between all of these?
Great, so it's 180 degrees.
So, if we think about the bonds
that are forming -- oh I
see our TAs are here, so you
can start handing them out,
because we have two minutes
left to go.
So, as they're very quietly
handing out your class notes,
let's think about what this bond
is here, this boxed bond,
is it a pi bond or
a sigma bond?
It's going to be a sigma bond.
So, we have sigma 2
s p, carbon 2 s p.
So they're two s p
bonds combining.
Now let's think about this first
pi bond, which will be
above and below the
bonding axis.
Is this pi or sigma?
This is pi.
So we're talking about pi carbon
2 p x, because it's the
x axes combining to
carbon 2 p x.
And the last bond that we have
here is a carbon-carbon bond,
and this is our last p orbitals
that are coming together.
These are the ones that are
coming right out at you, so
this is going to be on
a second pi orbital.
So this will be pi carbon
2 p y, carbon 2 p y.
All right.
So, we'll stop here today.
Just stay in your seats for
another 30 seconds as they're
handing out your notes.
I want to mention that you're
going to get problem-set five
is posted today, and I'll
write which ones you can
already do so far, because you
don't have class on Monday.
But remember that you do have
recitation on Tuesday, so that
could be very helpful with the
problem-set, so be sure to go
to recitation on Tuesday, and
have a great long weekend.